when I first started with minimalism of
course my first question was what do I
want out of life what do I want out of
minimalism and how can minimalism help
me improve my life okay that's not one
question that's like three questions
that was basically kind of what I wanted
to kind of first figure out for myself
that after I kind of defined that and I
knew that I wanted to escape materialism
I wanted to have less stress I wanted to
have more time with my family I wanted
to escape my shopping addiction and quit
focusing on having more things and
obtaining more stuff only to have more
things to manage maintain and organize
so I knew what I wanted but then my next
question became okay but now what how do
I actually do that and what do I
declutter so today I'm going to share
with you 50 items that I have
decluttered from my life I can
definitely think of more but these are
just some ideas to get you kind of
started or maybe to help you think of
some things that you might possibly not
have thought about that you could do
without I love Joshua Becker's
definition of minimalism and it's the
intentional promotion of the things that
we most value in life and the room
removal of anything that distracts us
from it what a perfect definition so by
no means does this mean you have to
declutter all of these items it's really
about having the things that we most
value and removing that excess removing
the things that burden us but hopefully
they can give you some ideas of where to
begin and be sure to share your own
ideas down in the comments below let me
know what are some items that you have
decluttered from your own life that way
we can have an exhaustive list to help
each other along the way okay without
further Ado let's get on with the list
first up is the television my husband
and I have decluttered our television
years ago I have a video all about why
we decluttered it and how it's actually
changed our lives it definitely impacted
our marriage and it's just made us a
whole lot happier as a family so I won't
really dive into that because I have
separate videos on that next up is
Netflix and Hulu my husband and I
actually did have Netflix and Hulu at
one point and for a while we were just
so busy doing other things that we kind
of would watch them every now and then
and I just kind of became an extra
expense out of the month and so that
became something too that we also didn't
really want to focus too much on if we
really wanted to watch something there
are tons of documentaries for free on
YouTube which tended to be kind of the
things that we used to watch anyway we
didn't really get too much into the
series and things like that because then
we found that it became a negative habit
where we would binge watch especially
the kdramas I loved the kdramas and that
which became something that we would
spend up until like two or three in the
morning watching kdramas and for what
like so we could be exhausted the next
day
um we just decided to cancel these
things and especially we didn't have a
TV anymore it was the perfect time next
up is video games this is not something
that I decluttered it was actually my
husband but he was definitely addicted
to video games and he made the decision
when we got rid of the TV to get rid of
his video game console and he tells me
that he's a lot happier because of it
because video games for him was
definitely an addiction one hour would
turn into two three and the next thing
he knew he was up at midnight when he
had to get up at 4 30 in the morning the
next day to go to work for him getting
rid of it became something that just
bought him so much more time he felt so
much better by doing other Hobbies so
like woodworking painting things that he
had kind of left out of his life he
could kind of go back into and it didn't
make him feel drained at the end of the
day Awards and certificates that's
something that I decluttered for my life
when I was in high school I had this
like big box of like certificates and
medals and things that I had worn one
when I was in school it was something
that for a while I kept and I realized
that I had to declutter it because this
was something that that when I was in
high school when I was in Middle School
it really just when I was a kid in
general I wanted to have Awards and
things because I thought that if I
obtained my parents approval and then
they would be proud of me mainly my dad
that I would feel the love that I craved
and so really when I started minimalism
and I was going through my things of
things that I should declutter I
realized that some of these items that I
had didn't bring me joy especially my
Awards and my certificates they didn't
bring me any Joy because I realized I
didn't do it for me I was doing it for
someone else and so getting rid of that
it was so freeing if you have any
particular items that you have in your
home that remind you of something sad or
that you realize you had these because
of what you wanted somebody else to
perceive you as I think it can be
incredibly freeing to get rid of these
items this next one is a vacuum we have
laminate flooring the home that we lived
in before has laminate flooring so I can
just use a broom I don't see a need for
a vacuum this one might sound odd but my
wedding dress favors cards just wedding
related paraphernalia I ended up selling
that my husband rented his tux there was
a lot of things that we had for our
wedding that we either sold or rented so
we definitely had a cheap wedding and
for us it really wasn't that big of a
deal to get rid of these items because
it's not about the physical stuff it's
about the relationship that we have and
the memory that we had and of course we
had photos to to remember those things
so I didn't feel a need to keep those
things souvenirs I think that's this
one's can be a pretty easy one to get
rid of but it's also something that we
not really we don't really purchase and
anymore for other people if we do travel
we tend to get things that they can eat
like candies especially when we go to
Mexico there's different kinds of
candies that they have there than here
so that's something that can be kind of
enjoyed that doesn't add extra clutter
to the home toaster and a mini oven at
one point we did have both of these
things and I don't know I just we got
them we got married because we thought
that we should have these things like if
you have a home you just you have to
have a toaster in a mini oven but it
really I figured out that I could just
use a griddle for pretty much anything
and we didn't actually need these items
dishwasher and dish rack this is
something that we got rid of when we
moved into this home because the
previous home also had a smaller kitchen
and the dish rack just always seemed to
kind of collect items and so when I
initially was starting with minimalism I
thought well what if I just declutter
the dish rack itself and then it will
stop attracting all the piles of dishes
because that would force me to actually
wash and dry dishes immediately well not
immediately I mean sometimes after
eating but I find that for us it
generally keeps the a kitchen clean
typically not always but typically hair
curler straighteners dryers and just
hair related appliances I used to have
several of these kinds of items and I
would constantly curl and straighten my
hair but I found that it was just
causing more damage so then I had to use
these items in order to make my hair
look healthy and it was just gone
constantly never-ending cycle of
damaging my hair making it look like
it's healthy making a damage more and I
just decided I was done when I was in
high school I chopped my hair it was
actually down to my waist but it was so
damaged I chopped it and decided that I
was not going to use any of these items
again I mean I have like two or three
times like I think for my wedding uh and
and just special events that I borrow I
don't actually have these items because
I use them maybe two every two three
years so for me I find that my hair has
been a lot healthier now that I have
removed these items and I don't use them
lotions creams body scrubs face washes
and just all sorts of personal care
stuff basically Castile soap is what I
use as a body wash it I basically use it
in a a little foaming container in order
to use it as a face wash and then I also
use coconut oil as my lotion so that's
my conditioner I sometimes whiten my
teeth with that with baking soda I mean
it just basically Castile soap and
coconut oil is like my personal care for
pretty much everything tampons and
disposable pads I have had disposable
pads and a menstrual cup for years now
and I love it I could not see myself
going back because I used to have like
these packs of menstrual pads and packs
of tampons that would just take up a
bunch of space they would cost money all
the time they'd harm the environment and
these things that I've had I did spend a
little bit more up front but I haven't
purchased these items in years I can
leave a link down below for the ones
that I particularly use but know that
everybody is different for uh menstrual
cups there's definitely a learning curve
so just kind of do a little bit of
research before you actually begin it's
also a lot easier for women that have
had children like me so just kind of do
your research figure it out but I love
these and I definitely don't see myself
going back to those statement jewelry I
used to be one that would constantly
have these different like cheap
necklaces that I would trade out for
different outfits so different colors to
match my purses to match my shoes oh my
goodness I had a horrible shopping
addiction I had like an array of purses
an array of necklaces and it all kind of
mixed and matched and I now have jewelry
that I love it's good quality that I
wear pretty much all the time
this one's a simple one straws I just
don't really see that it's needed I mean
you can just definitely drink from the
Cup itself if I really wanted straws
then I would probably buy like a
reusable straw but I just don't see a
need for straws in general so we don't
have these Ziploc bags uh we purchased
reusable Ziploc bags so you could also
use mason jars or just your plastic
Tupperware containers in the home so
that you don't have to constantly buy
these things but a word from the wise do
not put a knife in with your fruit
inside the Ziploc bags because um
who would have thunk that it would
puncture the bag
disposable dish sponges I have used
cloth sponges for a while now and I love
these things you just throw them in the
washing machine and use them over and
over again so no more disposable sponges
for me
pre-made mixes I used to really dread
making bread and baking and things like
that and that was really I think because
I didn't have the practice but once you
kind of start doing it a few times
you'll find that actually making things
like bread is a lot easier than you
might think aluminum foil clear wrap and
parchment paper for parchment paper we
use a little silicone roll thingamajig I
don't know what it's called so I'll
leave it linked down below but for Clear
wrap there's a different option that you
can reuse it's like a beeswax cover and
then as far as aluminum foil I don't
know I just I don't cook with it I don't
really find a need for it I don't know
of an alternative though so if you know
it let us know down in the comments this
next one's a biggie and it's sentimental
items from previous relationships or
just items in general that remind you of
things that are sad or they kind of keep
you stuck in the past
and I I decluttered all things from
previous relationships even before I
started dating my husband as a way to
kind of free myself and say it's okay to
let go I want to move on I want to have
a better life I want to have a different
life going forward and so it was
definitely freeing I think that the
items that we have in our home can
really say a lot about our memories are
just what things we value and if you're
keeping something that reminded you of a
previous relationship is it because
you're still wanting to hold on is it
because you're you're afraid to let go
what are the reasons behind that I I
would say probably take some time to
actually think about those things and if
it's something that you're ready to let
go of then give your give yourself
permission to do so with love and
compassion the sex one is social media
obviously I am speaking on social media
now but I've actually been without other
forms of social media for even longer I
actually went for two years without any
form of social media including this
YouTube channel and then that was kind
of what prompted me to make this YouTube
channel but but before that I had
completely experienced many changes in
my life and the comparison trap the
constantly wanting to buy things to look
like somebody else to have that perfect
life that they have I think that it all
just kind of feeds on itself that it
would make me constantly want more
things because I wasn't enough and I
didn't have enough so eliminating social
media helped me make huge strides
towards minimalism a lighter one throw
pillows I used to have tons of pillows
on our bed we still have some pillows in
our bed I don't sleep without a pillow
but I'd have just pillows just for
decoration that would constantly just
throw off of the bed that were never
really meant to be slept on until I
realized why do I do this every single
night I have to pop these things off put
them back on the bed so I just
eliminated them all together bottled
water we don't buy bottles of water
anymore I have my Yeti water bottles
that I absolutely love because they keep
things cool in the summertime and they
keep things hot in the winter time but
besides that we have a Berkey filter so
we constantly just have clean water and
we just don't need to buy bottles of
water anymore a dresser a decluttered
big bulky items like a dresser we had
this very large dresser and once I
started to declutter clothes and get rid
of things I realized I didn't need to
put things in this particular item maybe
if you have big bulky Furniture pieces
in your home once you kind of start
decluttering
it actually can open so much more space
getting rid of the bulky items not only
that but you can make some money off of
them so kind of look around your home
and see what big bulky Furniture pieces
can you get rid of to clear up some
space in your home get rid of some items
that you are probably stuffing in those
drawers and also make some money off of
it specialty cleaners I think again
baking soda vinegar castles so pretty
much clean any surface so I don't have
any special like floor cleaner wood
cleaner all those sorts of different
things I just basically use the same
stuff for the entire home plastic cups
plates and silverware I don't know don't
really find a need we can just wash dry
and put them away and it keeps our home
neat and clean and kind of removes that
expense disposable razors for the
longest time I had an electric shaver
and it worked very well but as my skin
has improved with the eczema now I have
used a safety razor and I love this
thing and it's actually super cheap and
the blades have been something that have
lasted me throughout the entire year and
will probably easily last into the next
year cookbooks this one I think is
something that my fantasy self wanted to
have because I really wanted to be like
this Gourmet Chef or something I don't
know but I would never actually go
towards these like elaborate recipes so
if I really wanted to make something I
usually look up a YouTube video on how
to do it because I want people to show
me like what they actually put into it
how they actually do it I just don't
find a need for cookbooks carbonated
drinks this is something that I did a
long time ago back when I was in high
school I originally started from
carbonated drinks to juices then to
tease and then now I could pretty much
drink water with my meals and I'm
perfectly content flower vases and wine
glasses I used to have both of these
things and I think that a mason jar can
pretty much do both in one paper
calendar I don't have paper calendars I
have Google Calendar I absolutely love
it I share a little bit more about that
on what's in my iPhone video if you want
to check that one out baby shoes and one
time outfits let's be honest if you have
a baby they wear them for like 30
minutes and then they outgrow them so I
never really purchased one-time outfits
for our kiddos a lot of the things that
we had that were nicer were actually
like given to us but most of their
clothing I would just purchase used they
don't remember
baby food maker and just baby fancy
gadgets I think that a lot of the things
that are sold to new mothers are just
mothers in general are things that we
don't really need I had so many things
that I realized why did I even buy this
like I never used it it was never really
helpful
um I think babies need a lot less than
we actually think they do battery
operated toys and just battery operated
stuff in general we do still have a
couple of battery operated toys that
they use a lot but I try to eliminate
those one because they're just highly
stimulating they kind of remove their
need for using their own creativity but
then also because I just don't want to
have to constantly be like buying
batteries and replacing Batteries and
Things I do have a reusable rechargeable
batteries but I just didn't want to
bother with that either so so this is
something that I haven't like gotten rid
of completely because we still have a
couple of them but it's something that I
absolutely don't buy anymore so along
with that is disposable batteries
because like I said I've reduced the
items that we now have that are battery
operated we don't need as many batteries
but we have rechargeables and so we
don't have to constantly buy these
things for those items paper towel rolls
and disposable napkins every once in a
while there's a couple of people that
come to our home and they're like wear
the napkins I'm like cloth napkins like
it's okay but other than that like it's
it's never really felt weird it's it's
never really been something that we've
really missed and also it kind of
removes that extra expense as well along
with that is Kleenex or just face tissue
in general like if somebody is sick in
the home we have a designated booger rag
where we'll say hey this is my book a
rag like nobody wants to touch that
anyway so trust me we're not going near
that but um yeah if if we need to just
wipe our noses we get a rag toilet paper
we've actually never purchased Kleenex
or face tissue holiday Decor when I
first got married I was so excited that
I had a home to decorate and so I would
find myself constantly at the Home Goods
and Marshalls and and the Hobby Lobby
trying to find just decor items for the
home things that were absolutely
non-essentials uh I would constantly
change things for spraying and for
summer and for fall and um I decided I
was going to do away with that I didn't
want to purchase those things anymore so
I got rid of a huge majority of them
pretty much kept like the Christmas
stuff and I don't buy these items
anymore manuals it's pretty simple I
think if anything is kind of broken in
our home we're kind of trying to figure
it out honestly a huge majority of us
will probably look to YouTube to figure
it out like who's with me it's just me
I've tossed the manuals small kitchen
gadgets like lemon squeezers spiralizers
things like that things that you
probably never use that are kind of
stashed down in your drawer you don't
need those name brand purses and I guess
let's just call it my collection of
purses I used to have tons of purses
green ones blue ones small ones big ones
things that I would basically swap out
for different outfits that weren't
making me any happier that were just
cluttering my closet so I basically sold
a huge amount of them and donated some
of them and I now just limit myself to
one that I basically wear all the time
loofahs I used to buy loofahs dispose of
them like shortly thereafter because
they would just like rip apart and fall
apart we now use a wooden bamboo brush
uh it's been really useful for us we can
you know reach hard to reach areas and
um we just haven't had to use lupus
anymore shaving creams and depilatory
creams pretty much soap and water is how
I shave follow up again with some
coconut oil I don't feel that need to
buy those items anymore this next one
take it with a grain of salt but paid
personal care so things like my eyebrows
getting haircuts getting my nails done
waxes things like that that's something
that I don't really spend money on I
actually have gotten my nails done and
it's because I've been treated to it for
Mother's Day and things like that but
other than that I don't spend money on
these things I've cut my hair for years
I do my own eyebrows I just I basically
do my own personal care for me
personally I would rather spend this
amount of money that I would spend
paying somebody to do that for me and
having to drive there and back and wait
in line things like that I'd rather save
that money and that time towards a
bigger purchase that would bring me a
lot of value in the long children so for
example this piano that I have behind me
I had wanted to play the piano for years
but I always thought that's for rich
people it's something that I would
prefer personally to save that money
that I would be spending monthly on
something like this that I could do
myself towards something that I value
that will serve me better in the long
run just my personal preference so again
take it with a grain of salt if you have
the budget this is something that you
love that you treat yourself to I'm not
telling you to stop that it's just again
my personal preference Galla style
clothing and special someday clothing I
do still have a dress that is pretty I
mean I consider to be fancy but I wear
that every Christmas every winter time
but other than that I had like my prom
dresses that like when am I ever gonna
wear a prom dress again and I had like
four of them
I had a bad shopping addiction you guys
I don't know why I needed four prom
dresses like prom was done and gone so I
got rid of these kind of someday
clothing or just things that I would
love to aspirationally wear if something
were to happen and I sold them got rid
of them and I've never missed them large
bulky unused gym equipment again I think
that sometimes we have these like ideas
of the life that we want to have and the
person that we want to be like our ideal
self and we definitely fell into that we
had different sorts of equipment that we
rarely used I had a treadmill and I
actually did use that for a while but
then I found that I much preferred doing
body weight workouts and uh once I kind
of figured out that I liked that over
constantly running on a treadmill which
kind of made me bored I didn't really
enjoy it I gave myself permission to get
rid of it so I've sold that sold some
other equipment that we didn't use if
you bought some gym equipment you don't
find yourself using it give yourself
permission and the Forgiveness that you
didn't actually use it to let it go
maybe find a different type of workout
maybe it's not that you didn't want to
work out that you didn't want to
exercise it's just that that type of
exercise maybe just wasn't for you
waffle makers cake pop makers griddles
and other small appliances I actually
had all of these particular items and I
would retour them maybe like once a year
if that so I got rid of all of these
items and they cleared up so much space
in my kitchen and maybe you'll disagree
with me but I think a waffle pretty much
tastes just the same as a pancake I've
survived decorations and knickknacks
that I either don't find to be beautiful
or don't have sentimental value I heard
one time about visual clutter and I
started learning that if you go to a
museum you have this one wall with this
one painting and you can actually
appreciate that one painting because
it's not like cluttered up with a whole
bunch of other paintings that you're
having to like distract yourself which
one do I look at so when I got choosy
about the home decor that I had in my
home all of a sudden I could appreciate
so much more the decor that I did have
eyeshadows lip liners contouring sticks
and basically a huge chest of makeup I
do still have makeup I I enjoy makeup
but it's a very small amount I basically
have what fits in one little package
once something runs out then I buy
another one but I don't have any kind of
like trial items like eye shadows and
different colors of things I basically
have my one and if I did want to try a
different type of shade then I wait
until that one runs out before I
purchase a new one candles that I
purchased for looks but didn't ever
really intend to use I had a lot of
candles in the home like I'm telling you
I had like a designated closet for my
candles and lanterns and and things that
I would just kind of swap out with the
seasons I was so addicted to this that
this one was actually hard for me to get
rid of until I just decided I'm not
gonna do with this anymore I'm going to
enjoy Simplicity and enjoy just having
the same Decor throughout the year and I
got rid of these and actually I haven't
missed them books that I've loved that I
don't plan on rereading this one was
hard for me to get rid of as well
because I love books I love the value of
books I have been taught to appreciate
books and that they are a treasure I
mean somebody spent so many hours in
order to create this book that you might
have in your hands and just to kind of
let it go to me it felt like a waste
until I realized that I could donate
them to my library and that way if I did
want to reread them then I could go to
my library check them out but in the
meantime if I never do read them
somebody else will
so this for me was a helpful way to get
rid of something that is very emotional
to me and this next one I think this is
51 but it's okay is things for hobbies
that I used to enjoy but I now don't I
really wanted to include this even
though it's in addition is because
sometimes we have things because we want
to have a certain lifestyle like I
mentioned like we think of ourselves as
we're going to be this person we're
going to have this ideal life and
letting go of these items
can be like the death of a dream like
letting go of we're not going to live
that particular lifestyle I used to love
cake decorating and that was something
that I really enjoyed and then all of a
sudden I had kids and I had other things
to manage and suddenly cake decorating
became like work because I had to clean
and I didn't want to do all that and so
I didn't enjoy it anymore but I still
kept the Big Tub of all the cake
decorating supplies because maybe or
because it was a dream that I had at one
point and I spent a lot of money on
these items and my husband even made me
like a little cake turning table thing
and I felt bad letting go of these items
even though I knew it's not something
that I enjoyed anymore it wasn't
something I was going to do anymore so I
made up my mind that I would give them
to somebody who would enjoy them so
hopefully this list has been helpful for
you maybe there's items in your home
that you don't use that you feel like
you're never going to use give yourself
permission to get rid of them and maybe
find ways that other people may enjoy
them and that might help you have that
peace to let them go I thank you so much
for joining me today if you'd like more
videos on minimalism and slow and
intentional living don't forget to hit
that subscribe button so you won't miss
when I post a new video and also don't
forget to let me know what are some
items that you have decluttered in your
own home until next time bye for now